Houston Howard, Transmedia Author/Speaker: And
that's fun right but that's not the big takeaway.
The big takeaway is what are they doing like
think of that, think about what they're doing.
Film Courage: What can filmmakers
learn from the Pixar theory?
Houston: I think what filmmakers can learn
from the Pixar theory is just how fans think
and for people that don't know the Pixar theory
it is the unofficial fan theory that all the
Pixar movies exist in one narrative universe and
they're all connected in crazy ways. Where Pixar
the official line from Pixar is that all these
things are disconnected right and they don't
have anything to do with each other but fans
they've constructed their own crazy interconnected
universe and so what filmmakers can learn from
that is that innately fans love connection,
they love things to cross over, they love the one
story that they love to connect with the other
story that they love. They desire this and if
they don't see a connection they will figure out
how there is a connection and if you look at fan
theaters not just the Pixar theory but just like
any fan theories there are fun and interesting but
it shows that the psychology and the mentality of
the modern fandom that they crave connection. You
look at something like the fact that if you watch
episode one of Star Wars in the galactic senate
scene there's a pod of aliens that are all ETs
which means wait a minute that's ET is in the
Star Wars universe which and so now these things
are connected in a really interesting way which
then if you then go watch ET that explains why ET
reacts to the kid in the Yoda mask not because
he's an alien but the reason he reacts to the
Yoda mask is because he knows Yoda because he's
from the Star Wars universe which means if when ET
makes the bicycle fly at the end of the movie he's
not using weird alien magic, he's using the force
which means ET is a Jedi which is awesome and
fans will work all that stuff out and and which
is ridiculous but it's fun but it's ridiculous
but what it shows so we shouldn't discard that
as filmmakers say Oh that's just a crazy fan
theory. No, look at why the fan is doing that
and figure out what's the mentality and what's the
psychology behind that. They crave connection. You
think about this think about M. Night Shyamalan
what you know people haven't been excited about
M. Night Shyamalan in 15 years right? But then
when he made Split right which was a solid movie
and it was good but the best part of Split was at
the end when they were revealed the connection to
Unbreakable and that's when people said Oh
my goodness M. Night Shyamalan, he's back!
He imagined was great his filmmaking didn't
necessarily improve he started connecting
his stories and the fans got excited about it so
then you had Unbreakable then he connected it with
Split and then they converged those things into
Glass and and he created his own little connected
universe out of those three films which fans loved
and it really revived his career that one decision
to connect those films revived his whole career
in a great way right? Kevin Smith you look back
Kevin Smith who broke in with with the glut of
independent filmmakers that broke into the 90’s
the thing that separated him from all those other
filmmakers is the fact that he started connecting
interconnecting all his movies. His Clerks
connected the Mall Rats was connected
Chasing Amy which connected to Jay and Silent Bob
and they all existed in this little town in Jersey
and referred to the plot points of the different
movies in a really interesting way but still in
the way that they could still stand alone but
there was obvious there was a connection that
separated him from all those other filmmakers
and he created a community around his
IP [intellectual property] that other filmmakers
weren't able to do because they didn't connect not
and listen. I think Kevin Smith would agree that
he's not necessarily the best filmmaker of all
those filmmakers that broke in the 90’s right?
But he was able to build just such a rabidly
devout community because the fans were excited
about the connections between the stories and so
for me the Pixar theory is all about the fans
and the way they think. It's not about I mean
it's interesting to think about of like well the
witch you know the witch in Brave is actually the
little girl in Monsters Inc and because when you
see the witch's cabin, tthere's an etching of Mike
Wazowski and Sully in the wood carving of the of
the wall which then I think the theory says after
Sully leaves Boo at the end of Monsters Inc she
spends the rest of her life searching for him
and uses the magic of the doors to ultimately
like get trapped in ancient Scotland and but
she understands how to use the magic of the
doors to then turn people into bears and the
reason she turns them into bears is she's trying
to recreate Sully in her own life will always
without with tragic results and it's like however
the story goes right or the fact that I think that
the Pixar series theory says that if you watch the
end of Frozen Rapunzel and the dude that Rapunzel
Flynn that dude that Rapunzel marries they're at
Elsa's coronation which means they're connected
which then the theory said that Elsa's
parents died in a ship sinking accident
but they actually didn't die, the ship sank.
They actually made it to a deserted island,
restarted their lives had a son on the island
who was Tarzan and then the ship that sank was
the ship that the Little Mermaid explores at the
beginning of the Little Mermaid when she finds
the fork and all that stuff and they create all
this connection and that's fun right but that's
not the big takeaway. The big takeaway is what
are they doing. Think about what they're doing,
they're working hard to create connection.
That's what they want. They love it,
that excites them right? Connection excites, it's
why people…this is the brilliance of the MCU,
this is the burnings of what's going on with
the Mandalorian. This is even in video games
with things like Kingdom Hearts and when you know
a crossover character into a Mortal Kombat game,
we love crossover and connection. Look
at Chicago Fire, Chicago Med, Chicago PD,
all the biggest ratings events in TV are those
crossover events right? As a kid I loved it when
Scooby-Doo crossed over with Batman and Robin and
the The Globetrotters and there was the connection
like we the fans always loved that stuff and it's
always played out which makes me wonder why would
a filmmaker ever make things without connections
to other things. If you do, you're going against
the psychology of the audience because the Pixar
theory first and foremost shows the mindset of the
modern fan which means when you create something
and you're not connecting anything you're going
against the expectation the audience and you know
ultimately that's I think if you if you create
things understanding your audience and understand
how they think and what motivates them and what
they like if you read up on this philosophy called
phenomenology. Phenomenology the philosophy of the
highest, the greatest artistic achievement of the
artist is not the art itself, it's the experience
that you create between the audience and
the art. The experience is the achievement,
not the art. But the only way to get the
experience is to understand what the audience
wants and how to create that experience with the
art and it's the combination that creates the
experience. You have to understand the psychology
of the audience if you want to create that magical
experience and the Pixar theory gives us a
very clear window into how the audience thinks.
Film Courage: So is that why people
love crime podcasts or puzzles
because we're connecting, we're trying to connect?
Houston: Of course I think it's just how
we…that's how we operate. That's how we work,
how our brains work and so we're
always trying to connect pieces and
our brain does it for us sometimes subconsciously.
Just how we like these interesting connections
and it plays out in entertainment whether it's
superhero stuff, whether it's what The Walking
Dead has been doing with crossing over all
their shows whether what Hanna-Barbera did
way back in the day, whatever NBC does crossover
events has been a staple of modern entertainment
for decades so this isn't a new thing, it's
always worked right? It's working even more now in
a sort of a modern multi-platform transmedia
market but this isn't sort of a new development.
It's always worked right so I think understanding
as a filmmaker understanding the psychology of the
audience and creating content that connects
with other content it's gonna going to
just increase your chances for your entertainment
to really succeed in today's market.
Question For The Viewers: Do
you believe in The Pixar Theory?
Any other fan theories you believe?